We're here in the Arthur M. Sackler Museum of the Harvard Art Museums and
we're here with Doctor Robert Mowry, who's Alan J. Dworsky Curator of
Chinese Art and has been here at Harvard since 1986.
One of the extraordinary features of Harvard's Chinese collection are a
series of bronzes from the Shang dynasty.
Perhaps you could just say a few words about the technology of
making these bronzes.
Sure.
These bronzes are made using a very complex method that was not used any
place else in the world, most any time, maybe until the 20th century,
maybe, but not before that.
It's called the piece mold technique.
And the way they did it, they first made a model of the vessel in clay,
which they fired to give it strength, durability, and a very hard surface.
Then they would take small pieces of clay and put them over sections of the
vessel to make the mold itself.
And that's why it's called piece mold.
It's in numerous different pieces.
After they have made impressions from the model, decoration was
carved into the model.
Never forget that one of the glories of these vessels is that everything
that you see on the surface was integrally cast
with the vessel itself.
There is very little cold working, that is post casting, chasing,
chiseling, and such.
It is integrally cast so that that decoration, for the most part, was
incised, engraved into the model, so that when you put the piece of clay
against the model and then pull it off, it would have part of the shape
of the vessel and part of the decoration.
Of course, those being clay and the bronze, when its mold's going to go
in, is going to be very hot means that the pieces have to be fired.
This is a difficult part because whenever you fire clay
it's going to shrink.
And so then you have to have pieces that even though they have shrunken
still fit together perfectly.
And then you would bind them together.
You have an inner mold, otherwise you're going to have a completely
solid vessel.
Little pieces of bronze called chaplets that hold the interior mold
away from the pieces of the outer mold when it's all set.
You put the molten bronze in.
Of course, the whole thing is upside down.
The reason being when it's upside down, you don't want any bubbles.
There are going to be bubbles in that molten bronze.
When they rise to the top, you want them on the bottom of the legs, where
no one's going to see them.
So it's a very complex process, but it gives superior casting results.